so tonight it's prime time not in the
booth for phillip rivers but on the
field against the tennessee titans
odds provided by points bet sportsbook
the official sports betting partner of
nbc
sports let's do some props derek henry
titan's running back been down a little
bit lately
over under 80.5 rushing yards against
that great colts defense
yeah i mean it's going to be tough
sledding running the football
against this football this defense with
the cult so they play a lot of eight-man
fronts
deforest buckner is an under the radar
defensive player of the year candidate
he's a guy that's like you know mike
he's our perfect you know
f the play up type guy he really is he's
so disruptive he's everywhere the stats
don't really tell how good he is
darius leonard uh another just
phenomenal football player you watched
him last week against lamar jackson i've
never seen anybody at a linebacker
position
more comfortable with attacking lamar
tackling lamar jackson in one-on-one
space than ever
i'm gonna go over here but like just
barely over
i i'm not gonna like i i think they'll
stay patient with the run because they
know this is a really good defense and
they need to stay patient with it to
open up some play action pass and things
like that
but you know i it i think it'll be a 24
rushes for
85 yard type of game i could see that in
this one
yeah look it's not going to be easy and
and this is a guy who
typically starts slowly and then finds
his stride
he started fast this year and has kind
of fallen off a bit
and if he's going to make that push for
the second half it begins tonight
remember it was that thursday night game
a couple of years ago against the
jaguars
when he just exploded right
onto the scene and he's never looked
back since then
that's the kind of night that i think he
needs tonight if the titans are going to
win this game
comfortably and maybe they won't maybe
it will be kind of a grind it out game
and it's going to be a close game and
derek henry's not going to
not going to pop the way he did against
the jaguars when he went why would he go
99 yards in that game
99 yeah i mean tony he had the 97 yarder
this year i mean
you know they feasted on some of the
poor defenses in football in the run
game
i just can't imagine them feasting
tonight and one thing we've all like
forgot a little bit with tennessee
hey their best offense alignments out
for the year
taylor won i mean there's there's no
like as soon as he's gone out
they have not been as dominant in the
run game i you know i don't think
there's
any way to really you know finagle that
conversation he's a damn good player so
that's hurt them as well um
but this calls d it's real they're
they're the real deal
next prop will quarterback ryan tan
he'll throw an interception so i guess
that would put the over under at 0.5
chris what do you got
um i'm going to say yes
i'm going to say he throws one tonight i
will but this defense their ability to
pressure with the front four
all the time drop seven into coverage
i think you know big plays will be tough
to be
tough tonight where he'll probably have
to squeeze some ball into tight windows
i say he makes one mistake tonight yes
brian tannen
has 19 touchdown passes three
interceptions on the season
yeah the indianapolis defense has 11
interceptions tied for the most
in the nfl i'll go with you one
interception tonight for ryan tannehill
all right aj brown
over under 63 and a half receiving yards
for the tennessee titans
i'm gonna go over here i am because i
just think the play-action pass will be
a big deal
and the other thing mike you've heard me
say this you know when you the colts
they play that seattle scheme on defense
that it lends you to being able to play
some one-on-one football
out on the edge you know you to where
you know like
like we've seen in in other weeks dk
metcalf against the 49ers same
scheme right on the defensive side of
the ball oh we'll just attack them
attack them
our guy's better than your guy to me
that that
tennessee would be stupid not to take
advantage of that a little bit
the colts defense is awesome but it is
the corners are not
top notch they're not they're zone type
corners to where i would think they
could play just a little hey we're
better than you
type football and he gets over 63.5
yards between that and the play-action
pass
xavier rhodes has been great for the
colts this year after he was much
maligned by
the vikings fans and media and for good
reason he had fallen off dramatically
he's had a resurgence this year last
year
he allowed an 84 percent completion
percentage in coverage that was 83rd out
of 84
cornerbacks in the nfl this year he's
allowing a 45
completion percentage that's the best of
all corners so
something happens sometimes you get cut
you get a new
start you get a different defense you
get a new
breath of fresh air and you turn it
around and kudos to rhodes for finding a
strong second act to his career right
and you look at him right you see him
he's trimmed up
he's not as big as he was in minnesota
that's the first thing i see when i look
at him i just go he looks like he's in
better shape this year
and you know a little bit like richard
sherman leaving seattle and going to san
francisco too
i don't sit there and just go oh you
know he blows me away or anything like
that i just go yeah he's he's real good
he's a really good corner he does not
great but just real good
but when you have he's in the great
system fit now too that's the other
thing
you know we talk about it's the perfect
thing for him hey
jam the guy at the line of scrimmage run
back and don't let them get
deep and we just talk their pass rush is
phenomenal so
there's not a lot of time for these
quarterbacks to make decisions and let
people work down the field on xavier
roads too so that plays hand in hand
there and
that's why it's a good marriage so far
one of my great regrets this year in
picking games
was forgetting that
when rhodes was with the vikings he
neutralized julio jones
yeah every time they played the falcons
and without roads
jones ripped up the vikings defense so
uh yeah rhodes still has it and he's
proven it this year and that's going to
be a factor tonight most likely
philip rivers will he have a completion
of 40 or more yards tonight chris yes or
no
mike this is something we didn't hit on
in the first hour that i do think is a
little bit
part of their issue of why their offense
isn't as good we talked about the
running game right and some of that
you know rivers you know that there was
a little of an issue with the chargers
the last two years you know it's a
little like drew brees in the fact that
he's just not going to scare you
throwing the ball real deep down the
field yeah there'll be a lot of 10
15 20 yard throws he's more aggressive
than drew brees don't get me wrong
but but it's not going to be like oh
we're worried about the 50-yard post
over the top or
guys just blazing by us on the outside
and he's throwing 50-yard go routes on
the outside
you know that this is a little bit of a
problem with them
and i'm going to say that they do get it
tonight
they do with t.y hilton being back in as
bad as this titan's defense
has been in the pass game no pass rush
i think it'll lend itself to one at
least one completion of over 40 yards
yeah i i'm gonna go what are you gonna
do
i go under just because you went over
yeah i don't have any high level
analysis it's just a gut feeling it's
gonna be under even though ty hilton
will indeed
be playing rivers only has two
completions of 40 or more yards all
season i'm
comfortable sticking with the under all
right jonathan taylor we talked about
him
earlier frank wright the coach of the
colts says they still have faith in him
over under 42 and a half rushing yards
what do you think
um i i i'm gonna go i'm gonna go over
i am um that offensive line
it's not again it's not a great
run-stopping defense with tennessee
there's no aspect of the tennessee
defense where you can look at it and go
that's special right now no
there's really not so i i think they're
they're
they realize if they go up two pass
heavy vrable can get kind of creative
with
some of the coverages and blitzes he can
bring they'll stay patient with the run
and i think he'll definitely get over 42
and a half
yeah i'm going to agree with you and i
think he's going to have reason to
re-establish himself after what happened
last week with that fumble that chuck
clark returned
for the touchdown after he made phillip
rivers look like anything
but the free safety that he was 20 years
ago
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports